DALE MARKOWITZ: So
today we're building
this sort of DIY pet
cam for tracking what
your pets do while you're gone.
Whether you want to know
whether your dog's hanging out
on the couch, or your chickens
are trespassing on the porch,
or your cat's just doing
some casual software
development while
you're gone, we'll
build an app that runs a machine
learning model on your phone
to detect events,
like dog on couch,
and then sends you a
notification on Slack.
It'll also save snapshots of
those moments to the cloud.
So let's get to it and build
an ML powered pet cam that
runs on your smartphone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the cool things
about this project
is that we're going to do the
computer vision part entirely
in a web app that can
run on a smartphone.
It'll be privacy conscious, so
we'll only send a notification
or save a picture to the cloud
when your pet does something
that you care about.
Otherwise, your
video and your photos
will stay entirely
on your local device.
I'm building this pet cam with
my colleague, Jason Mayes,
a developer advocate and
host of the YouTube show,
"Made with TensorFlow.js."
Hey, Jason.
JASON MAYES: Thanks
for having me, Dale.
You know, we've got
a ton of old devices
like smartphones just
sitting around doing
absolutely nothing.
So I really wanted to think
about how we can give those
a new life in a way that
anyone can then replicate
and hopefully use to
do something useful.
DALE MARKOWITZ:
So why a pet cam?
JASON MAYES: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So essentially, I saw a
lot of people around me
these days buying
kittens and puppies.
And I think it'd be quite
fun to kind of track those
as they're growing up
to make sure we're not
being too naughty when
you're leaving the house
when they're alone.
And of course, you
can always extend this
to other objects in
the future too as well.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Kind
of like a chicken.
JASON MAYES: Yeah,
like a chicken as well.
Anything could be possible.
DALE MARKOWITZ: All
right, let's do it.
OK, so our app's going
to work like this.
First, we'll build a
pet tracking camera
app that runs on your
phone and detects
common pets like cats and dogs.
Then we'll make our app
tracker even more powerful
by training a custom pet
model on Google Cloud
to detect chickens.
[CLUCK]
And finally, we'll
connect our front end
to a back-end
built-in Firebase so
that we can store data and
send messages to Slack.
JASON MAYES: OK,
so let's talk about
the actual front-end
application that tracks animals.
The first step is to
enable the webcam access
and load a TensorFlow.js
model for object detection.
Today we'll use
the COCO-SSD model
that recognizes 80
common household
objects in any picture
that you pass through it.
Now, importing TensorFlow.js
and the machine learning model
is actually really simple.
First, we've got two script
tag imports for TensorFlow.js
and the model itself.
Next, we can grab a
reference to the video object
that we're rendering
our webcam to.
And once we've got that,
we can call COCO-SSD.load.
We can then call model.detect
and pass it the video elements
on our web page to classify
the current frame being
played from our webcam.
So once we can detect what's
in a given video frame,
we then need to send an alert
when the pet, in this example
a dog, gets close to an
object that we care about,
such as a food bowl,
couch, or a bed.
Here, we simply allow
the user to choose
from the objects a model
can recognize to make
their selection as shown.
And we ask the user to
ensure the device is set up
in front of the object we
want to monitor once enabled.
Then, when we've detected that
the user has placed the device
in view of the object
they want to monitor,
we can continuously
check the video stream
to see if a chosen pet ever
gets close to that object.
To do that, we
calculated the distance
between their bounding boxes.
If a distance is less
than some threshold,
we'll send an alert
to our back end
to then send a notification.
Now, we also had
to add some logic
to avoid spamming the user with
too many notifications in case
the dog came in and out
of frame continuously,
which you can learn all
about over in our blog post.
So check the link in
the description after.
And that's essentially
how the front end works.
If you want to play with
yourself and grab the code,
you can find it over
on Glitch.com as shown.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So after
Jason built the front end,
we can start testing the app.
But the problem was that
Jason and I actually
don't own any pets, so we
had to get kind of creative
with our testing setups.
JASON MAYES: And I also borrowed
Benjy the corgie from a friend
to check couch and
ball alerts for dogs,
which caught him every
single time, as you can see.
It actually went
better than expected.
DALE MARKOWITZ: But
then, in the middle
of working on this
project, I actually
did acquire some pets--
two baby chicks.
But despite how incredibly
adorable they were,
our pre-built TensorFlow model
didn't really recognize them,
so I had to figure out
a way to adopt pet cam
to work for my chicks.
Which brings us to part two,
training a custom chicken
detection model.
I did this using Vertex
AI, Google's new machine
learning development platform.
Look at these cute
little data points.
AutoML Vision is a tool
within the Vertex AI platform
that lets you build a vision
model without writing any code
and then export it
to TensorFlow.js.
First, in the
Vertex AI console, I
created a new image
object detection data set.
Then I uploaded about 100
pictures of my new baby chicks
to Google Cloud
Storage so they could
be imported into Vertex AI.
After the data imported,
I opened an image
and annotated it by hand.
I decided to train the model
to recognize Moira and Millie
separately because they're two
different breeds of chicken
and I thought it would be
super cool if the model could
tell them apart.
I also annotated the position
of their food and water
bowl so that I could
calculate when the chicks were
eating and drinking.
Then I just did
this 100 more times,
and it took about 30 minutes.
When I was done labeling,
I hit Train New Model
and then selected AutoML Edge
to create a model optimized
for an Edge device.
I named my model, selected
some configuration options,
configured it to train for five
node hours, and then waited.
When my model was done training,
I checked out the precision
and recall in the Evaluate
tab, and this model
was pretty accurate.
To actually use it in my app,
go to the Deploy and Test tab,
click TensorFlow.js,
and then choose
a location in cloud storage
to export the model.
From here, we can
download it and use it
right in our app's
JavaScript front end.
All right, now let's
connect the back end.
To make this app
actually useful,
we want to save these pet
events when they occur
and then send an alert
to the user over Slack.
For this, I of course turned
to my favorite serverless tool
kit, Firebase.
When the front end app detects
that a dog's on the couch,
it saves a snapshot and some
metadata about the event
to Firestore.
Then I built a little
app, a front end,
to pull data from that
Firestore database
and then display it
as a sort of diary
so that you can keep track of
all the cute or mischievous
things that your pet is
doing while you're gone.
To set up Slack notifications,
I use a Firebase Cloud Function
to call the Slack API.
It's set up with a
trigger so that when
data is written to the
Firestore database,
it automatically triggers
my Firebase Cloud Function
to run and then send an alert.
And that's it.
That's the whole backend.
If you want to learn how to
build a pet cam yourself,
check out the code in the
blog post linked below.
JASON MAYES: You
can also check out
TensorFlow.js and
other premade models
you can use on our websites.
And of course, if you
want more inspiration,
check out #MadeWithTFJS hashtags
on Twitter and LinkedIn.
DALE MARKOWITZ:
By the way, if you
want to see how my
colleague [? Marcue ?]
built his very own pet
cam that runs on device
as well using Coral,
then check out his take
on a very similar project here.
I guess great minds just
think alike or something.
And if you do try
this yourself, make
sure you let us know
in the comments.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]